- YouTube, what's up?
So so grateful that you clicked
and you're about to
watch a new YouTube video
but before you do, 212-931-5731.
That is my texting community platform.
I'm doing a lot of one-on-one
engagement in there
and also access, opportunity, first looks,
in that environment.
212-931-5731.
Join it now and now to the video
you've been wanting to watch.
- I understand, I run into it every day.
- Your conundrum is deciding
at what price point
your customer's actually
gonna pay for your stuff.
- Well, that's part of it.
- But you can also segment
those audiences, right?
Those two audiences are looking
for very distinct things.
- They are but they cross
over in what they see.
So how do you keep 'em both?
- What are you guys
talking about?
- Ben's an artist.
Prints versus original pieces.
Original pieces obviously
go for much higher value
than the prints do
but they're both sold
on his website.
- But I just started
an online gallery
where you can go on and buy a print
for any size frame, dadada.
- But they're fundamentally
different products.
- They are.
- The only vulnerability you have
is if you don't have
secondary market dynamics
on the originals.
The reason they're
fundamentally different things
is not necessarily, to your point,
if you're physically in
love with the picture--
- That's all that counts.
- Well not really
because in my perspective,
well, let me rephrase,
in one man's point of view,
I would argue it's not
because for example,
I don't care what a
baseball card looks like.
I care about what I believe
its secondary market
value will be over time.
If I cared what a
baseball card looked like,
I wouldn't have just paid $17,000
for a Bill Russell rookie card.
I would've bought the replica
for 18 bucks off of Ebay.
The real business you're in
when you're in that business
is having the potential to
create investment growth
on the original
because that's the variable
difference of the product,
not the print or the original.
- Agreed.
So do I take down my site?
- No.
- What happens when Judy Monitz
from the Aramark Art Festival
goes on my site and she's like,
we're not gonna accept this guy?
- Well, I assume that the
same thing that happens,
it all depends on where your
leverage is on that KPI.
If you believe you're the kind of artist
that doesn't have the leverage
because there's print versions,
as you can imagine, you know this,
every single great painting
in the history of time
has had print versions.
So if your worry is actually B2B,
which it is in that environment
where somebody's making a judgment call,
you need to attack that in a
conversation with that person,
not make a macro business decision.
If that is the thing you're debating,
then you go in and actually
have that convo and say,
do you Jenny, Judy, do you value this
or does this skew you in
any way for considering me
because I value the
awareness that you create?
And then she gets to decide.
She goes, no, I don't give a fuck,
everybody does that
or she goes, yes, and
then you make a decision.
That's how I see that.
All right, getting right into it.
This portion is like with me.
So I think this is when
you need to get selfish.
Like you need to ask your question.
Hiring is guessing,
firing is knowing.
Like you gotta go fast.
That's how you get shit done,
that's how you figure shit out.
This is the television.
And the television is the radio.
So 4Ds, mother fuckers.
Would love for you guys to do intros
and tell me about your business
and then we'll go right into hardcore Q&A.
- Sounds good.
Great to meet you, Gary.
Wesley Bowl, Civil Resource Group.
We're a security risk management firm
headquartered in San Francisco,
office in LA, about to be in New York
and great to be here.
- Great to see you.
- [Ben] Ben Bonehart, artist,
just started an online gallery.
- Where are you from?
- Nyack, New York.
Pleasure.
- [Will] Hi, Will McCoy,
I'm the CEO for NoBully,
which is an international nonprofit
antibullying, anticyberbullying
based in San Francisco
but we do work worldwide.
- Understood.
- [Ken] Hi again.
How are you?
- Hey brother.
Good.
- Ken Maskowitz, Spanky
as my friends call me,
CEO of Ad Zombies.
We write words that sell anything.
We are an at scale copywriting service.
- Yep.
- I'm French, I'm David Larocz.
So I'm obsessed by why
the best are the best.
So I travel the world to meet
top performers, athletes,
entrepreneurs to
deconstruct how they think
and then I provide a lot of free content
on what I learn from them
and it gives me a lot of credibility.
I'm 30 and now I'm lucky
to have Olympic champions
and entrepreneurs to help them
to grow what they do faster
and also be more fruitful
because I love psychology
and we have the biggest
following in France right now.
But the most important thing for me
is that we change lives.
I receive like letters
from 15-year-old kids
who didn't commit suicide
because what we do
and it's amazing for me to see that.
My next step, and it's why I'm here,
I want to go global.
I want to have that
kind of impact worldwide
and I would love to have
your advice and tips
on how I can liberate
my accent and who I am
in order to reach more people.
And just for you to know,
it's not, for sure I
love the business part,
but it's a mission for me.
I'm playing for the next 50 years.
I want to create a legacy
and I want to impact the
lives of millions of people.
I say that because
sometimes I hear you saying
that young life and business
coaches are full of shit,
and it's true,
but for me, I work so
hard in the last 10 years
and I make differences.
- It's very easy not to be full of shit
if you're playing for legacy
versus signing people up to masterminds
to buy watches and skis.
So I'm with you.
- I wanted to commit suicide
so I do what I am doing
because it changed my life.
- That's great.
- Yes.
- Good.
With a small group,
hopefully we can go around a couple times,
very specific questions
like we did with Ben.
I'm ready to go.
- Super.
So little bit of context,
we got to chat recently,
so I'll dive right in.
Four legs to our stool,
consulting, training, research, solutions,
shifted from a hybrid
government and corporate focus
to just companies now.
That's interesting from a
content and digital perspective
'cause now we can lean out a bit more
and talk about who we're working with,
the type of work we're doing,
those types of things.
One of the challenges we've
found specifically has been
now that we're in that space
and can kind of develop content,
start to do more in the digital space,
is thinking about audience.
So in the corporate space,
our prospective client or point of contact
is very disparate.
So could be a chief HR officer,
could be a chief security officer,
could be the CEO,
could be the COO.
- Or the spouse of those people.
- 100%, 100%.
So as I think about
kind of how we go about
our content development,
what are your thoughts with
respect to targeting strategy?
- If you have a limited
resources, you pick one.
- Got it.
Start there, make that deliver.
- The lever is, all of this is built on,
it's gonna be your answer as well,
all of this is built on context.
Everyone's infatuated with the content
'cause it's important,
it's the output, your world, my world.
However, all the upside
from a strategy standpoint
is understanding context
because then you're able to
create content contextually,
which disproportionally creates relevance,
which relevance and meaning
something to somebody
is why every person in this room
is wearing what they're wearing
or what they're gonna eat
is what they're gonna eat.
So to answer your question
in a world where like,
hey Gary, I'm crippled,
it could be the CFO, could
be the CEO, could be the CHO,
I'm like cool, pick one.
It's really as simple as that.
My argument is you can
get to a lot of them
by understanding copy.
There is no question to me
that a PDF, a deck, an audio
file, a video can be made
and if you rant on it as first person
or if you create something amazing,
it can actually touch on
all three of the demos.
I can talk about the
financial impact of something
and the retention of employees
because of that decision
and the top line revenue growth
probably within two minutes
and then if I change the
copy on a LinkedIn post
that expands on that
and targets a CFO
and really just narrows in on
the financial ramifications,
I've now actually made
one piece of content
with an additional five
minutes of post copy
that did make it seem as if I made three.
- Right, okay, great, super.
- That's how I think about it.
And I know we got a lot
done with fear and not fear
and stuff like that.
So I'll just keep going around.
This is all about investment.
I spend an ungodly amount
of time on investment
for things that drive my CFO crazy.
You know what's so funny about me?
Is people say I don't listen,
I interrupt people, this and that,
I just have so much pattern recognition
of being an entrepreneur
my whole literal life
and I spend so much time listening
when I'm not in front of a camera
that I gave you the answer
within the first four seconds.
We're gonna go through it
'cause I want to make sure
you got the T's and the I's
but we'll go right back to it.
This is a 100% investment.
What's your appetite for lack of margin?
Because there's no other way.
Which also speaks to
having to be able to be
in a place where you're
growing the offense
while you're spending
more time on the defense.
Knicks last night were within three
and decided to put a
defensive unit off a time out,
which made sense,
except that the Bulls scored
five points in two seconds
and we were back down by eight
and had to call another time out
and put back out the offense.
That's the decision Couch Fizdell made.
Luckily the Knicks rallied and won
but that would've been the
critical point where he lost
'cause he decided at that point
it was time to invest in defense
and unfortunately, the
market, AKA the Bulls
said go fuck yourself.
That's your game.
All the top line revenue
you're gonna give up
because there's only so much,
entrepreneurs like you and me
think we can do 280%, not 100%.
It's just not true.
There is a number.
Some can do 280
but that doesn't mean you can do 390.
And so that's the game.
The only other variable in
your life to play this out
is what you're willing
to give up in leisure
or time efficiency.
Most of what I'm successful at
is completely predicated
on actually having four minute meetings
when it's a four minute meeting
instead of a 30 minute meeting.
If I'm really starting
to understand myself,
I'm like oh right, zero waste.
Creates vulnerability
because you have a meeting and you leave
and nobody knew what
the fuck you just said,
but I'd still rather do that
for four minutes than 29 minutes
because then once I realize a week later
nobody knew what I said
you have another eight minute meeting
with the context of them not knowing
and you get it done
and so now you're in for 12 instead of 30.
- I'm a little dizzy.
(laughing)
- That was a good one.
I know, that was a good one,
that was a good one.
That was a little nerdy.
- Mine's a little more, not as complex.
So I did my 10,000 hours
on the creative side
of branding and advertising and--
- Did Malcolm Gladwell give you a bow?
- Pardon?
- No.
Unforgiving, and about five
years ago I decided after,
well just to go back a little bit,
I got divorced and started
thinking what can I do
versus what I can't do
'cause I can't do it.
- Good for you.
- So I started painting
and I realized that
five hours would go by,
it seemed like 10 seconds.
And so I started doing that
as therapeutic exercise
and people started asking
me how many I'd sold
and I ugh, so I started selling 'em,
I'd done about five
years of doing art shows
and 15, 20 art shows a year,
showing my work, selling it
and that's a lot of lugging,
it's a lot of insight
from the marketplace,
what people like, what they don't like,
I loved that,
I loved interacting with people,
I love selling the art work.
- Yep.
- Then I decided, okay,
how do I monetize this
beyond selling original artwork because
everybody's an artist.
So I just recently started
this online gallery
on this platform artstorefronts.com
which is set up for artists,
you don't have to do a lot
of the development work, and
I sat down and started
to figure out to myself,
okay, I put a lot of brands on the map,
how do I do it for myself
and that's why I'm here
because I'm not quite sure
how to position and package myself
to appeal to the two markets
that I'm trying to appeal to,
which is the person that's
going into Homegoods
and buying a $40 piece of shit
and to the person that's gonna buy
a $3,500, $4,500 piece
of original art work.
- Well, as you can imagine,
you need to be in different places
and you need to show up different.
But the good news is
there's only 10, 12, 15 places
on top of something called the internet
that are good places
for people that don't
have millions of dollars
to spend on media.
And the reason every word out of my mouth
has been TikTok and LinkedIn
over the last four months
is my expertise over the
last 25 years as a marketer
is to understand where there's
attention for a good price.
Zero's the best price.
The fact that you can
post a one minute video
of you painting on TikTok right now
and get 800,000 views for zero dollars
is not available to
you, sir, anywhere else.
The fact that people sit
around and say things like,
well I can't do that,
that's where my 14-year-old
granddaughter lives,
there's only kids there,
people say no instead of yes.
Has anybody heard of a granddaughter,
first of all, that's not true,
it's getting older by the second
but let's just say it was.
Let's just say it was capped.
It is only 12 to 16-year-old
females in America for TikTok,
which it is not,
but let's just say it was.
Has anybody heard of a granddaughter
taking a phone and
showing their grandmother
this cool painting?
People are so funny.
They're in the business
of no instead of yes.
So whether it's TikTok or LinkedIn,
those are two very
important platforms for you
because you have to make
content for those platforms
because you're probably not gonna pour
$10,000 a month in ads.
You may, I have no idea of
anything about you, you're not,
so those you have to take very seriously.
That is the context
that I need to do a
better job to my audience
of why I talk about it.
I just did it,
I'm glad I did,
I hope Jason caught it,
that is the punchline.
Forever, it was email, it
was organic Google search.
The reason I would sit and
spend seven hours a day in 1999
looking at the ASP code of my website
was I was getting educated
on how to show up first on Google
without buying Google Adwords,
before there were Google Adwords,
for the word pinot noir,
because if I know I did,
147 people would go to
winelibrary.com in 2000
for no reason other than
they searched pinot noir
and I showed up first.
And then I bought ads
because they were five cents
and that was a good deal for me
and I could afford to buy $10,000 a month.
And on and on and on.
I'm not throwing around my phone number,
212-931-5731, for my community
text platform for my health.
It's because text messaging my audience
converts better than
anything else I can do
and is the only thing that I've seen,
including Twitter and Facebook
that looks like email
looked like to me in 1997
where 90% of the audience that
signed up actually saw it.
You need to produce content
in written, audio or visual,
clearly video form for what you do,
across the 10 platforms that matter.
We have that,
I don't know if we've done that,
I don't know if we do that later,
did we do it already?
- [Male] Zach just came in.
- You need to do that.
You need to deploy self awareness
and figure out which
one of those you can do.
Your business is highly visual.
So we're gonna kind of need you
to be in picture and video form.
Even if you were in video form
and people only saw
your back of your head,
it could be a fucking tool
time Home Improvement gag
if you were so insecure,
and I don't say that in a razz way,
I say it in a compassionate way,
if you were so insecure that
you couldn't show your face.
Great, let's film you back
to canvas to audience.
But you need to produce pictures
and videos on the internet.
It's more important than making the art.
If nobody knows, you can't sell shit.
- Right.
- When I tell you
that I started this company 10 years ago,
which got made fun of by
every one of my friends
'cause building a client service business
is not a smart business
for where I was at in
my professional career,
it's because my belief
was there was nothing left
except communication.
If tomorrow, I decided
to pick a random artist,
I would make them be the kind of artist
that can sell $5,000 paintings
because I would outcommunicate everybody
and that would create demand.
The end.
- Got it.
Thank you.
- Now it becomes,
now what I just said to you is
oh, you want to get healthier?
You have to eat well and exercise.
And you're like, not Botox?
I'm like no.
You're like not ass implants?
You're like not detox tea?
No.
Not steroids?
And you're like got it.
Now you have to do it.
And the way I best learned
that people will do it
is how I got to you have to be self aware.
You might love to write.
And that may sound crazy
to a lot of people,
like he's a fucking artist that writes,
I think it's kinda rad.
If you wrote a crazy manifesto,
and I'm glad to hear you're
a good writer, on LinkedIn,
with no visual support
that you just magically enamored all of us
with the written words
of how you came up with the painting idea,
and then there was a
click out to the painting,
that might be intrigued.
Less people would see it
'cause of the friction of clicking out,
more people may convert
because of the way you did it.
You've got to play.
The thing I'm most proud of is I play.
I'm okay with not doing well
in likes and shares or
what's best practices
because I know I have to figure it out.
Yesterday, doesn't mean anything to me.
Let me rephrase,
yesterday means slightly less to me
than trying to figure out today.
I love the context of yesterday.
I'd like not to repeat the same mistakes,
and I'd like to use what I've learned
to deploy in the context
but today's the game.
Not three years from now,
I know VR's coming, not interested,
not three years ago.
Everyone's so scared
that they massively overvalue yesterday.
- Yeah, so I'm struggling with myself
about turning the table
from being behind the camera
to being in front of it.
In other words--
- There's a way to do it,
maybe not be in front of the camera,
right back to the back.
- Well I'm using that
as a metaphor but just--
- Yes, that's exactly right.
- Selling your product
and now I'm the product.
- Correct.
That's just insecurity of
the product you're selling.
- Well yeah.
- I'm aware, I know you know it.
That's just you casting
your own judgment of like,
I don't have permission to
do this, I just started.
Guess what?
LeBron was good his rookie year.
Maybe you're just fucking
naturally talented.
- I am, I'm incredible.
- I believe it.
But honestly, honestly, that's it.
That makes much sense
based on the narrative.
You're like, fuck, I just took this up,
who am I to charge 5,000?
- No, it's not that, it's not that.
It's the entering into the
marketing myself as the product
versus marketing this gentleman's
business as the product.
- That goes to the insecurity
of the product, my friend.
I'm telling you,
whether it's the version of who am I
or you've overvalued being understated
or you philosophically
have put being behind
the scenes on a pedestal
as a more proper way to go
and you're not a
charlatan or a fame whore,
whatever you've decided in your brains,
that's what we have to break down.
- Yeah, probably all the above.
- I believe it.
They're the cliche reasons.
- Right.
- People are like, Gary,
personal brand, that's so yucky.
I'm like, cool, call it reputation.
Is that better?
I got to step out for two minutes.
I'll be right back.
Yes sir.
- Ready?
- Yes sir.
- So for us as a nonprofit,
we do great work,
nobody is probully.
So the argument is easy.
But when it comes to
converting to donations,
converting to new partnerships,
getting that, going from
awareness to active leaning in.
- Yeah, I'm super excited
we're talking about this
'cause I'm going to a
Raised By Us event tonight,
which I'm on the board of,
and I'm on the board of Pencils of Promise
and Charity Water.
I would argue that some of
the best marketing work in my,
I'm very funny,
I'm very comfortable in
promoting my business ventures
'cause I like capitalism,
but I'm very, very quiet with my altruism,
but I spend a lot of time on it.
I'm gonna give you a
really interesting insight.
The number one vulnerability
to nonprofits is audacity.
If you macro analyze the
communication of nonprofits,
they speak to us as if
we should donate to this
and it completely
fundamentally turns us off.
Why should I?
- [David] You mean like
to educate people on their interests?
- If you look carefully,
and I'm very passionate,
it's funny to have Spanky here,
it's funny, I'm so bad at grammar,
forget about I was,
just 'cause the way I learned
and probably because I'm probably dyslexic
and because I'm an immigrant,
there's a lot of reasons probably
but nonetheless, I'm deeply
passionate about words,
I'm good at it as a human.
They matter
and when I got into nonprofit work,
I wanted to be effective.
It was like here comes
the whiz kid in marketing.
I'm like fuck, I better,
I rarely do work
but I did some work on this.
And I'm also very intuitive,
back to quick answers,
I'm like oh fuck, these guys
are terrible at marketing
because they're entitled and audacious.
And then when I started
really getting into the world,
and I'm not speaking for you,
but I was stunned by how many people
are nonoperational in the nonprofit world.
You have a lot of people,
it makes sense, right,
both my kids could go that route,
you go away from the wealth creation
and you're like I'm gonna give back
but you've never done anything.
So not only was it
audacious and condescending,
it was ideological and not practical.
So that is the huge
vulnerability to why nonprofits,
in the macro, without knowing anything,
I think you need to
really think about that.
How is that manifesting
in what you're creating?
The answer is, listen,
it's so fun to have the
prime of my life's work
being built this communications framework
that made no sense when I did it,
is starting to make
sense to people right now
but they're still grossly underestimating
what I'm actually doing.
There's nothing left but what I'm doing.
Everything's a commodity
except the awareness and communication
'cause of how life actually works.
Of course that camera's a higher quality,
of course, print and
original is different,
of course, bullying's
different than cancer
but it's more commoditized
than people think.
What's not commoditized is the ability
to get somebody to know and care.
To getting somebody to know and care,
you first have to deploy
empathy, not audacity.
It's the reason we have such a problem
socially in our country.
There's no empathy from either direction.
Literally yesterday
morning on the way to work,
I had a 15 minute
conversation with a woman
who told me that I was a very bad guy
when I spoke at a company last week
because I was using white privilege
because I was cursing
and if I wasn't a white male,
I wouldn't be able to do that.
99.999% of people would've
deleted that email
'cause it was pretty left field.
I spent 15 minutes talking to her.
I didn't find anything new
but I appreciated the conversation.
You need to be really smart.
You're right, nobody is against bullying.
More importantly, nobody actually cares.
And once you get to that realization,
and here's why, you know who cares?
The person who's kid becomes presuicidal
because of bullying.
The same person that
cares about heart disease
the second their dad
dies of a heart attack.
We have to get more empathetic.
But we deploy too much ideology.
I'm spending my life giving.
I don't need somebody yelling at me like,
Gary, you don't care
about fucking the turtles?
You can't drink out of that fucking straw.
I'm like, I get it,
but you're wearing a Gucci bag
and textiles are
destroying our environment.
We're in hypocrisy, audacity
mode in nonprofit land.
What we have to do is go into
contextual creative at scale
to create relevance.
There's a video that I want you to watch.
It was done by Sandy Hook.
It was really good.
Remember that?
I don't know if you guys saw this
but I was actually talking to Katie,
'cause it was a big piece of contention,
not contention, it was a big
conversation at VaynerMedia
'cause I believe in long form
videos instead of commercials
and this was one of
the best I'd ever seen.
It was a video of what it looked to be
is like a high school
love story, you remember?
- [Male] It's a great one.
- But it ended up being in every scene
while you were paying
attention to the sweethearts,
the mass shooter was in the background
and you only figure that out at the end.
- [David] See the data.
- I mean I got crazy goosebumps.
It's a three, four
minute video on YouTube.
It crushed.
- Sandy Hook Promise.
- [David] Can you write it?
- Yeah, you know what,
we'll have Nick send
an email to all of you.
He's probably looking it up right now
if he's not eating
and he'll find it.
The point is,
what's amazing about bullying
is it's a subconscious
knowledge that it's a problem.
And what you need to do
is make a two minute, 14 second video
that is entertainment or information
that captures the national,
Coney, nobody fucking cared
about that dictator in Africa
until everybody saw it on YouTube.
Got it?
- [Male] Yeah, thank you.
- How I think about it
is the Gary Vee model,
which is the Vayner model,
which again, Zach probably spoke to
and with Nick here and others here
we can go deeper into,
I think your organization
needs to put out 100
pieces of content a day.
I think that's what
you have to figure out.
I'd rather you spend
two hours less painting,
I'd rather you fire three executives
who actually aren't doing shit
but being in meetings.
You have to make.
This is about ideas and making
and nothing else.
When you make that your religion,
you start actually figuring out,
everyone's like, Gary,
I had an employee who's
been here for seven years
say to me on the phone the other day
when I said we have this huge
Proctor & Gamble conversation
and she's like, "Gary,
this is the staff we have.
"You have to make a choice
between LinkedIn and Facebook."
I'm like no I don't.
You have to stop being
in dumb fucking meetings
for two hours a day
and make it 41 so I can have both.
Figure it out.
You have to make
and you have to have
African Americans in it
and Asian Americans in it
and Latino Americans in it
and Latino Americans in Spanglish
'cause then you might see,
whoa, why is this resonating?
We didn't even now that this
was an underlining issue
in the Latam community in San Antonio
but by making,
when you make 100 pieces of content,
you start making a San Antonio
Spurs piece of content,
you see where I'm going?
That then gives you an insight
because you're getting feedback
and now you're like,
now we know what two minute video to make.
Let's make a video of an 84-year-old
and what bullying actually meant
and how it transpired
and what it actually meant.
This is not about suicide
and mass shootings.
This is about an 84-year-old
who's had 75 years of unhappiness,
has four divorces that
were ugly, not good,
has a drug,
you see where I'm going?
And that's just one,
I just went into hypothesis mode.
There's 700 other things
you could go with.
But for you and for you
and for you and for you
and for me and for every single person
this is a game of
contextual creative at scale
deployed against the platforms
that actually have the attention of people
which then compels people to do something.
And it is not one vanilla piece of content
seen by everyone.
It is contextual creative at scale.
As you can imagine,
now we're going very farfetched,
but if you're making a video
of a make pretend grandma
that had a painting in her kitchen
for that kid's whole life
and that's why you need
to buy one of my paintings
for your kitchen,
that's gonna strike a chord.
- It's funny you say that
because I tell people
when they buy my art that
it's touching their lives.
They're gonna be looking
at that all their life
and their kids are gonna be looking at it
and you can't put a price on that.
- Yeah, it's why I don't buy art
because that doesn't do that for me
but I want photos of my family everywhere
'cause that does do that for me.
But to your point,
many, many people,
most people actually do do that with art.
- I remember everything
in my parents home.
- I get it.
- I'm actually regurgitating
that onto canvas.
- No, I totally get it.
- I'm not an art follower.
My grandfather's has
a Rosco and I love it.
- That is your requirement.
It's awareness.
But it's not just awareness,
it's compelling somebody to do something.
Compelling somebody to do something
is based on them, not on us.
So we talk down
and we need to talk up.
Got it?
- Got it, thank you.
- That tone, if you go through,
just every communication you do,
comes from that filter,
you'd be stunned by how
much more money you'll get.
- [Male] That's very helpful, thank you.
- You got it.
- So as my brand has grown
and as we have developed
kind of a global awareness now,
we have clients all over
the world that use us,
the opportunities for me to speak
and take bigger stages
is occurring more often.
And so looking at growing
the business further,
I realized and recognized very quickly
that every time we document those moments,
every time we film those moments,
that then turns into more content.
But it's not necessarily content
directed at the brand.
It's content around my brand,
my personal brand.
So in looking at growing
the brand further,
we're trying to figure out
should we leverage the opportunities
of me speaking on more stages
and of me coaching or
working with other companies?
Because it's interesting,
the questions that I was asked a year ago,
year and a half ago were,
hey, how do I write effective ad copy?
Now the question is,
can you tell me again
how you grew a business
from zero to seven figure business
in like less than two years?
- Do you always answer
I listen to Gary Vee?
- I do.
- I know you do,
that's why I'm making that joke.
- But it's funny,
I had this really surreal moment
in the Nashville Airport.
I was speaking at a conference
and this guy comes running up to me
and I shared that,
I sent you an email about it,
I said, "This guy came running up to me
"and he like, can you sign my book?"
And I'm like, "Sure."
And he said, "Your book changed my life."
I'm like, "How?"
Because I was kind of
in the mindset of Ben.
- I get it, on the receiving end.
- Right, but now that's
happened a few times
and I'm like--
- The answer is both, to your question.
- Both.
- Of course.
- So it's okay to
diversify in terms of the--
- Do you have any partners?
- My filmmaker today
is my business partner.
When you said get an ops guy,
my video guy couldn't be here today
so Brandon came along.
So he is a blessing to my business
that came directly from my conversation
with you two years ago.
- I remember, I remember.
So financially, you share the business?
- [Male] Yes.
- That's the only vulnerability.
The only vulnerability to
building a personal brand
as a top of the funnel
is who are the other stakeholders
who fear that you're getting
disproportionate leverage
and can leave and they're the commodity?
- [Male] I don't think Brandon
has an issue with that.
- Well I can't speak for Brandon
but I can promise you
that's the answer to the question.
The only reason anybody on Earth
should not build personal brand at scale
is because somebody else who
has financial vested interest
subconsciously or
consciously doesn't like it.
Nothing else should stop anybody.
Because it brings business in.
It's top of the funnel.
- And by the way, your
LinkedIn strategy, holy shit.
And it's not even just weekdays.
- Brother, I know.
Listen,
eventually people are gonna understand.
I'm really great at what I do
and I'm very quite unusual
for giving it away for free at scale.
And then if you want it
deeply more contextual,
sure, there's things like
VaynerMedia, there's 4D's,
there's other things but like,
it's going to be like that forever.
By the way, if there was
documenting and video and YouTube
when I was 22,
I would already be there
because I would've done the same thing
and everybody would've
gotten email and e-commerce
and search and YouTube.
You would've seen me make a YouTube video
four months after YouTube
came out and said,
this is gonna be the biggest thing.
And then we'd be sitting
here, you'd be like,
how the fuck did he know that?
- Yeah.
Based on what you've been preaching
with the LinkedIn strategy,
I've been doing that aggressively
and I'll see on an average
day 150 to 300 new followers.
I'll see on a weekend,
2,000 new followers.
And I posted--
- LinkedIn is Facebook.
- It's crazy.
- 2012.
Solid platform.
- I've said it
a billion times.
Nobody's doing, very few people
are doing anything about it.
What's ironic is my advice
actually leads to my own downfall.
If everybody listened
to me and made content,
then the organic reach would go down
'cause it's just supply and demand.
That's how much I know
people don't do anything.
I'm literally giving
advice every single day
that is at my own detriment.
- So you are coming
from an immigrant family
and I would love to have your
point of view about that.
So the French business is growing.
- It's a family business?
- No, it's my business.
We are making four millions
that's here in France.
You say a lot about publishing
out a lot of content.
So we did 500 videos in Nice.
And the only thing that work
is when I do videos with
other English-speaking
well known entrepreneurs.
But when it's just me myself, it sucks
and I would love to have your vision--
- What's the definition of sucks?
It doesn't get as many views?
- Yes, a lot less of what I can do
when I do videos with I don't know,
a well known entrepreneur in some field
or the producer of Lord of the Rings.
It makes a lot of views.
- But that would happen
if it wasn't just English.
That's not a French/English
thing or accent thing.
That's a you're leveraging brand equity
from somebody who's famous thing.
- But in France right now,
I make more views if it's me speaking.
- Because you have more
brand equity in that market.
- Yes for sure,
but also I can see that,
so my question is,
if you were coming right now
in the USA or your father
with not perfect English,
how you would leverage--
- By recognizing
I can't change my accent.
- I do, even if I improve it.
- [Ben] I wish I had his accent.
- I'm sure.
We're not talking about
getting girls here now.
- It's not about my accent.
It's more like--
- I understand what you're saying.
- How do I,
I'm sure that I can leverage
who I am as a strength
but it's more--
- By having more patience
and just putting out more content
and by understanding that
Americans are naturally
deeply rooted in America.
More than 50% of Americans
don't have a passport.
So what you have to do is accept the truth
and execute on the truth.
- Because it's like,
I can see the growth of
doing more interviews,
I can see it's growing,
but me doing, after 200 videos,
it's like the same views at the beginning.
I don't see improvement.
- I understand.
And that's frustrating.
I think there's a couple things.
One, just continue to interview.
- Yes, for sure,
and I love to do that.
I do it even in French
as a kind of researcher.
- It's similar to some of the
stuff that we talked about,
I'm very,
blogging.
So I'm right about email,
I'm right about Google,
I'm right about e-commerce,
I'm right about search
and here comes this thing
that I think's about to
be big called blogging
and I look at it, 2002
and I'm like fuck.
I can't write.
- [David] Me too.
- So I'm looking at it
in the history of my career,
from May 1998 to right this second,
there's only been one macro
trend that I didn't dominate,
blogging.
You're gonna have your accent.
- Yeah, yeah---
- Americans are never
going to accept an accent
more than an American accent.
You just now have to decide
what your strategy is.
There's two moves.
One, continue to interview at scale
and do no independent solo English videos
and then after three more
years or a year or every year
on fucking July 7th, try
one and see what happens
or go the other way
and beat them into it.
Believe so much in your message
that you can be an outlier.
Look, no different, I will tell you
that when I hit the scene in 2009,
wildly high energy, cursing,
I was wildly not accepted.
I had a lot of pushback.
I just made everybody succumb.
It's really your only two options.
- And I have one question about,
you say a lot about being yourself
when you do things like
videos and things like that.
What is like the line, the balance
between staying yourself in the video
but yourself can, for example,
I would not say that I'm an extrovert,
I'm more introvert,
so I learn to speak
because I do a lot of
speaking engagement but--
- There's a lot of people
that do extremely well
that are quite,
Tim Ferriss is not extroverted.
- Yes, for sure, and I
love what he's doing.
- Good, there's your answer.
What's right is that Tim's Tim and I'm me.
I hate when people try to be like me.
I'm wildly entertaining.
That's hard.
That's a talent.
I give a keynote like a
standup gives a performance.
That's not going to be replicated.
- [Ben] And you happen to
be very insightful as well.
- Yes, I'm other things,
to your point, thank you for,
what I think people get confused with me,
and the other way is they
just think I'm sizzle.
I would argue that I'm
underrated intellectually
because I'm sizzle.
Introverts are always
like, ah, I'm not like you.
I'm like, bro,
I get fucking completely disrespected
for my intellect and
insights because I am.
Your gift is your curse.
So I'm okay with that
and everybody think I'm
dumb, I'm a charlatan,
I'm full of shit,
I'm not smart, that's fine.
That's the point.
I think leaning into
your truth is the best
because it's the fastest and the easiest
once you get over the hump.
You gotta get over the hump of judgment
but once you're over the hump,
then you're fast.
I'm so fast
because I have no time
to dwell on the judgment.
You know what's so fun about these things,
it's so funny, analyzing,
the reason I thought
that this would be good
and I would be good
was how I started looking at Wine Library
the first full year after I left it.
It's amazingly interesting
when you can look at
something looking down on it
versus when you're in it.
It was crazy.
That first, I stepped
away for a little while,
but then the holidays came and like
I wasn't fully removed and I was like,
this sucks, this blows, this
is shit, this is fucked up,
I'm like, fuck, those are
all my favorite moves.
But I'm looking at it like this
versus being there every day.
Your thing is so easy.
You have two moves.
If you want America,
you have two moves.
You keep going
or you keep interviewing
to build even more leverage
to then cash in
or you also start thinking
about distribution differently.
- [David] What do you mean?
- Well, one could argue
the psychology of the
end consumer in America
is different on LinkedIn than
it is on YouTube and Facebook
and thus your accent might
allude to European intellect
in LinkedIn that it may
not play out on YouTube.
- Yeah, for sure I can see
that the more it's about deep knowledge,
the less my accent is important.
- Everything's less important
once people see the truth.
Every fucking email I get
is like I started off hating you
until I started really listening.
I just would spend, no joke,
if I was your brother
and we were like hanging out
for the weekend I'd be like,
bro, not another minute ever in life,
you are not allowed to say to me
anything about an accent.
You're just wasting time.
That's what everybody does.
You understand?
I understand, I'm empathetic to it,
that's what people do.
They spend all their time
on the thing that they can't control.
- I don't do that.
It's like just I would like to have--
- No, I understand that, less.
- Less, okay.
- Less, that's all--
- Like never now.
- Correct.
That's right 'cause it's
a guaranteed variable.
- But my question is more
what could be the way
to not only not speak about that but
what I did in France,
every people told me,
ah, you are too young
because I started when I was 20,
and I used that as an advantage.
So it's not that I
stopped to speak about it,
I spoke a lot about it
and people have to say, ah fuck,
and in France at that time
nobody was doing that.
- You're super smart.
If you want to start your first video
every time in America, be like,
before you talk about my accent,
it's the Eminem Eight
Mile thing, of course.
If you take control of your shortcoming,
it becomes your strength.
- And I love that idea.
It's one of my message.
Use who you are--
- It's like those weird actors
that are super ugly
but they were smart enough to be like,
no, no, no, this is my look
and they're like,
oh, I'm weirdly attracted
to Adam Driver, why?
- Yeah and I would love that
for my audience to realize.
- I really think
that that's the new hack
that I need to make content about.
Hey, are you really not attractive?
I have an idea.
You need to lean in and reverse
and weirdly the confidence of
not being super attractive,
weirdly then makes people think you are.
I actually see it.
It's happened a couple times.
- [Ben] It happens to me every day.
(laughing)
- Let's get a couple more in.
Little free form.
We've got five to seven more minutes.
- Sounds good.
Reconcile for me this notion of
be the CNN for your segment
but don't be developing selfish content
that's intended to basically--
- Interviewing, interviewing.
- Who would you think of in my context
for in the security space?
What type of interviews
would you see as interesting?
- Well it makes me think of Fox News
'cause those guys
are always scaring the
fuck out of everyone.
Look, I think this is what's so great,
you probably have a good sense
of in a security landscape
who has equity.
What I always say is look
at your B2B magazines
and look at the conferences
in your industry
and look who is on the covers
and look who are on the keynote speeches
and then invite them
to be on your podcast.
And all those people,
since I'm one of them,
always want to do a podcast.
Got it?
- Right, got it.
- That's how you map it.
And then you do some Google search,
random shit like, top 50
people in security and privacy.
It's just random work.
You'd be surprised how
many people say yes.
Even if you had,
again, everybody says no.
Why would Sarah McGoo,
the number three security
person in the world
go on my podcast?
I don't even have one yet.
Don't say no for the other person.
It's the first thing I've
taught AJ about VaynerMedia
'cause AJ's practical,
which means he goes to no
'cause he thinks what would I do.
And he would practically
look through everything
and say no.
I'm like, that's nice,
most people make emotional decisions.
Now you're in a crapshoot.
Don't say no for the other person.
The greatest accomplishment of my life
is I had a super duper overweight
nerdy friend in college
and I promised him that he
would get a super pretty girl
before the end of college
and it was a simple game of volume.
I finally got him by sophomore year
to ask everybody
and eventually somebody said yes.
That's life.
- [Ben] I thought it was getting a puppy.
- That works too
but it was a really interesting
exercise of my thesis.
There was nothing on paper
that made what I saw happen happen
for any logical way,
in its most narrow,
animalistic way of life
and it happened
because you can't say
no for the other person.
And you have to be okay
with a lot of no's.
And if you're not okay with a lot of no's,
you never get to that miracle.
- [Ben] Well as an artist,
you get used to no.
- Correct.
Everybody's used to no in certain things
and not in others.
I'm only used to no
and love no in business
but I also didn't like asking
girls out in high school.
I didn't like no in that context.
So that's the thing.
You super can be fine in one thing
but another thing, you're not as fine with
and it's just recognizing that
and just going to a yes culture.
It's just yes culture.
That's all it is.
It's just making,
I actually think it is practical.
What the fuck is gonna happen
if you email Colin Powell and he says no?
God forbid he says yes,
you're off to the fucking races.
Maybe he's bored today.
Maybe his niece said to him
that he needs to get on podcasts
and he doesn't know better
that yours doesn't mean anything.
- Right.
- Don't say no for the other person.
You went through this.
You probably were going wide at first,
that's what got you there.
Then you're like, wait a minute,
I always tell people
I'm the easiest when I
have something to sell.
You want to get to me, I'm impossible.
You want to get to me
when I'm selling Empathy or
K-Swiss sneakers, I'm easy.
Everybody's got an unlock.
- [Male] Gary, the
other day, I was pissed,
I sent something to you
as a little thank you
and they fucked up the thank you note
and I'm actually glad they
fucked up the thank you note
because I have been wanting
to sit down with you,
not for me,
but to have a real contextual conversation
about mentorship on my podcast
and I would love to, if you
have time, at some point,
have you come on.
- All right, send me an email,
I'm booking everything now for next year
and we got a lot of stuff going on
so I don't want to bullshit you
but I'm very open to it.
- [Male] Cool.
- I have one question,
you say that we need to publish
100 piece of content per day.
- "100," right?
To me--
- Yeah, it's not the
exact number my question.
I heard in one of your
videos that right now
you attract a lot of talented people
but like what could be your advice
to attract or to find talented people
to do all the things
when you are not at your
position right now yet?
- Colin Powell.
By making a video tomorrow
and saying, I'm looking for people.
Drock became the adjective
or pronoun or noun
or whatever the fuck you call
when everybody calls themselves a Drock.
I wasn't who I was then.
- So you mean like--
- You've got a huge advantage,
everybody here has a huge advantage.
Every 17-year-old in America
and in the world wants to be a creator.
People don't get it,
this has nothing to do with
leverage of the person.
This has to do with the interest
and supply of the makers.
Every fucking 22-year-old hey,
do you want to work at a shitty bank
or do you want to work at a corporation
or do you want to be a video blogger
and postproduce for YouTube and Facebook?
They'll take fucking,
10% are rich enough
to have their parents
subsidize them not making money to do it,
40% of them are smart enough
or ideological enough
to choose happiness over more of a salary,
and then 50% will say no.
Not to mention, there's a lot of,
my argument on creativity
is about to go in another direction.
I'm starting to spend a
lot of time on 60 to 90.
So I think copy's super important
and I have this wild ideology in my mind
that there's all these
retired men and women
from the Mad Men era
sitting in Florida and
New Jersey and New York,
72 years old, bored as fuck,
so tired of everybody saying to them
that they can't do anything,
that they don't understand
how to take a selfie,
meanwhile, in the craft of wordmanship
and putting together words,
blow away 98.7% of the people
'cause they have 40 years of experience
to go along with their talent
and would rip their arm off
to come to an environment like this
and work for $15 an hour to be copywriter.
I'm completely convinced
and I'm gonna execute on it.
- [Ben] You're correct.
- I believe it.
You can't 'cause there's too much scale.
- [Male] Damn it.
- There's supply.
No no, not damn it, awesome.
The world is abundant.
If I thought you could beat me to it,
I wouldn't have said it out loud.
- I love the idea though
because that's a real challenge
is finding good quality
people who can write
and we vet them.
- You have the people,
you have literally the people
who wrote the greatest commercials
and greatest print ads of all time
sitting right now, again,
let me say it one more time,
being made fun of for not
being technology advanced,
made fun of, oh grandma,
you don't know how to take a selfie,
you had it reversed and
took a photo of you.
Meanwhile, can literally
write the greatest copy in the world.
- [Male] See I tell people,
I don't want copywriters,
I want people who are
amazing storytellers.
- Of course, that's what
a great copywriter is.
I know what you're saying.
You're saying the literal interpretation,
we jumped on,
you mean the truth.
By the way, it's why
I'm a great copywriter.
I have no grammar skills
and would never get hired
by Jega Boutique Ray
or Vayner for that matter
'cause I don't know
how to put it together,
but I know how to put it together.
- [Ben] Well, the secret of copywriting
is write like you speak.
So there you go.
- [Male] Instead of like a machine.
- [Ben] Write like you speak.
- Even better, the way I
speak makes people do things.
So thus, that's why my shit works.
- It's a plus minus.
- Yeah, 100%.
- [Male] Gary, you said something about
you believe in long form.
More people are saying short
form, short form, short form.
I say long form too.
What are you seeing
for the future of that?
- Both will work.
If tomorrow, I found out
that Star Wars, the
next one is nine hours,
I would go and watch it
and if I watch a six
second vine that's shit
I'm out in two seconds.
- [Male] What do you think for brands
when it comes to presentation?
- Both, both, both.
Here's how it works,
for long form, back where you're at,
and I got to run after this, I apologize
but really good to see all of you guys,
all you need, it's like Dollar Shave Club,
Dollar Shave Club makes a video
and then everybody's like,
oh I got to make those,
all you need is one 13 minute film
about Fiji water that
actually fucking works
and all this is is a sheep world.
People don't think independently,
they need an example.
Make one video and
you're off to the races.
Our Dwayne Wade Budweiser
video really mattered.
Three minutes, 47, and
that's a long form ad,
but I think where people get hurt,
brands have spent,
brands have been ripped off
by fancy directors and producers--
- [Ben] And ad agencies.
- By every ad agency
to make these kind of like documentaries.
- [Male] That's where we've
had the competitive advantage
because the agencies have--
- You'll appreciate this.
All of it is based on merit.
Nothing scares me.
Make the best thing of something,
and you will win.
The answer's yes, just be good.
Facebook and YouTube and all those people
get mad at me for long form
'cause it's against their algorithms,
it's against their best practices.
My theory is make a video
that somebody wants to watch,
do you know how many people
watched my eight hour
vlog in fucking Dubai?
It was eight fucking hours,
they're sitting watching me.
This is not fucking Avatar.
Make shit people want
to watch, always works.
Have the freedom to make something
that people want to watch
when you're in client services
is a different game, right?
That's where things get hurt.
Lot of times, clients
get what they deserve.
People hire VaynerMedia
and then try to make us Macaya.
I'm like--
- Everyone's a designer.
- It's all subjective.
That's why, that's why.
All right, I got to run.
Love you guys, thank you.
- Thank you very much.
- Thanks Gary.
(group clapping)